at last on a sunny day in london
a breakthrough after years of
negotiation a deal to prevent the
world's tech giants from avoiding
billions of dollars of taxes
a deal many people thought would simply
never happen
it's a very proud moment whether it's
people operating in tax havens or as
digital companies we're going to level
the playing field and inject that
principle of
fairness into our global tax system the
details are complex but the deal g7
finance ministers have agreed
comes down to two key reforms a global
minimum and corporate tax rate of 15
percent to prevent companies like google
facebook and apple
shifting profits to low tax
jurisdictions and new rules to calculate
what they owe
and where while it could involve
billions more pounds of revenues
it's still unclear whether those rules
for instance would apply to amazon
now this might have happened in the uk
but the main reason it's happened at all
is because of pressure from the white
house and u.s treasury secretary janet
yellen
what you're seeing is a revival
of multilateralism a willingness
of leading nations in the g7
and the g20 uh to cooperate
to address the most critical challenges
facing the global economy and this
international
tax race to the bottom has been
a problem for many many countries for
decades
it represents a real watershed the last
time there was a global deal
on business taxation was all the way
back a century ago by the league of
nations so while there's still some
question marks about the ambitiousness
of this
there's no doubting the momentousness of
it but still there
are a couple of questions first of all
how will this actually work in practice
secondly beyond the g7 will other
countries
actually sign up to it ireland has drawn
in billions of euros of investment
thanks in part to its famously low
corporation tax of 12 and a half percent
but that rate is below the floor the g7
agreed meaning says its finance minister
a significant impact on his country well
from the modeling that we have been
doing
uh we have indicated that it could
affect up to one-fifth of our corporate
tax revenue
but what we've also been doing is we've
been planning for this
so those kind of revenue losses are
already
included in our budgetary calculations
of course
that depends on this deal getting
approval from the rest of the developed
world
that's not a given but the oecd the
institution which effectively wrote this
tax template
is confident today there was a very
broad consensus and there's more work to
be done there will be more conversations
and
in the end it's important to have a
global taxation system that is that is
overall fair
in theory this deal could bring in
billions for the uk in theory
it could stem the tide of tax avoidance
in theory it could change the
relationship between big business
and the state forever in theory
but here in london what once looked only
theoretical
has become that bit more real
ed conway sky news